bueno claramente los democratas no pueden
estar allí porque no se sostiene en el
desplázate tienes 40 eres senador si
alfombra a e hijo 53 el senador
El republicano también necesitaba cuatro
seno habrá de ser publicano si la cosa
hace voto para parar el
nominación derecho de guerra
estoy muy probablemente no va a pasar
practicamente imposible pero si yo
datos reales, creo que aparte de eso
pasos para el go moine esperaba que hubiera
palabra imposible democratas de acquar
Dudo esta situación señor
pero estos no vienen cuadrados y
el impacto y la aleación sa e imi barrett a
est y más alto tribunal i comunidad a
sousse fabius posiblemente él y el
compañía orientis álbum un dramático
porque es el primer robben bastante heroe
48 heinz ser de la corte suprema
anualidad pero se les llama la de
espero que el valle sea el durante el
comercial que se llama mons de 40 años si que
podrías ser y en 2060 son 40 años o
se actividad legal decepcionado canales si
nos reunimos conservadores y mo
del aborto ambiental
nuestra sospecha como larcan se del poder
che delal la ley de salute qué siglas
introducido por el entorno de pur obama después
que si piero matrimonio gay y lo
barra gay si transgénero e
tambien l'actitude asia rie y
migrantes a sé sólo de un cielo ha
como al oeste del cago de los sentidos de acción de
andar es si un pie de inmigrante ayuda
sombrilla federal nos vemos te llamo sparaco
Wed para tener help medica no puede
obtener permiso
desea la ciudadanía o la legalidad de
sobre inmigración viene eso
para que venga perdidamente para los
sentido conservador un homenaje completo
porque se apareció a sí mismo todo lo que nous
filas conservadoras casi además de
contra encantamiento deias barbara a la garganta y
origen cubano en florida no
considerado por qué no de la misma manera que dijeron
conservador super da deraa kit asia e
el aborto